Devolution was supposed to mean power
from the government to the people now to
me it seems that that power has been
hoarded in Hollywood it hasn't been
passed down to the parents and that's
why the academy program for example all
that means is parents get a greater
choice of who they want to go to um or
what sort of schools they want their
kids to that choice is not given to
Scottish parents and they can't work out
why Scottish parents shouldn't be
trusted to make these kinds of decisions
because they they make different
decisions you bet horses for courses
different families but I don't I've
always seen this as the Paradox of
devolution that your average Scot has
less power less control over their
school less control over the hospital
Health Service because ironically of
devolution